[Musique]
alors comme hélas pas mêlant va faire un
petit jeu on va faire le french texte
d'accord le test français
je vais vous montrer des fautes des
photos des photos de personnalités
françaises vous me dites vous me dîtes
si vous les connaissez ou pas sont des
personnalités françaises très connues
vous me dites ce qu'elles font voilà si
vous les connaissez si vous n'en trouvez
trois parmi les 10 vous devrez twitté je
suis tu vois là attention si vous
réussissez je dois twitté maastricht pas
amer constat un star instagram facebook
non je le fais pas moi même j'en
actuellement faire caca le fera et vous
sur votre page facebook sur votre
instagram
vous mettrez vous mettrez non mais pas
m'impliquer trop vous mettrez si vous
perdez si vous trouvez en trouvez pas
trop vous mettrez heil of the french
beau gosse baba cyril hanouna d'accord
si vous perdez je mettrai pas mais
l'anderson îlots most beautiful woman in
the world
d'accord je le mettrais la en direct ok
regardez première photo est ce que vous
connaissez cette personne on ne souffle
pas on ne souffle pas mot monsieur
râlant on ne souffle pas la traductrice
d'accord moi je crois que c'est zidane
au début c'est monsieur hollande qui
fait qui fait quoi comme métier c'est le
prix des biens et j'adore parce que
isabelle morini bosc
elle est toute fière de dire qu'elle
fait qu hollande il est président des
présidents qu'elle remet à la sur ma vie
c'est pas possible
attention deuxième faute au deuxième ça
coûte pas grand chose que vous
connaissez alain delon s'est pas d'abord
je ne sais pas si c'est bernard montiel
non je ne sais pas c'est le patron des
points soleil en france des uv
c'est un ami à nous bernard montiel tu
qu'on aime beaucoup attention troisième
photo epa oui quoi ah ça oui non quoi il
connaissait lui elle a dit julien doré
julien doré lui non je ne sais pas je ne
savais pas mais bon ces jeunes parce que
vous êtes rencontrés dans les anges de
la télé-réalité brandon de l'île de la
tentation
merci attention quatrième photo collée
vous ne connaissez pas non non c'est
igor et grichka bogdanoff et les
champions du monde du jeu tout à tuer
jacques gamblin
je vais t'emmener de latence au
cinquième foot on regarde collet c'est
lui aa à aa
les très bons alors nico nico nico nico
je sais pas son nom de famille nikos
non c'est pas dit comme ça c'est jean
dujardin jean dujardin
non je ne le connais pas rrc artistes et
oscar attention on a regardé sixième
photo je ne les connais pas alors
attention cinquième faute au regard des
lacets kenji ça après 7e photo merci
regardez ce que vous la connaissez l
aucune idée alors je ne sais pas non non
la 18ème poteau rire les unes personnage
très célèbre en asie je suis désolé je
connais le prochain est très célèbre en
asie il est connu dans toute l'asie
[Rires]
alors attention suis large mais celui-là
le prochain est ce que vous le
connaissez non non je suis désolé le
dernier j'ai perdu lui vous connaissez
pas tasser aussi c'est johnny hallyday
[Applaudissements]
mais là je les ai je suis pas française
donc c'est normal c'est normal france -
c'est normal elle connaît françois
hollande c'est l'essentiel
ouais ça ou pas aujourd'hui c'est
l'essentiel voilà qu'un jour c'est vrai
mais j'étais jeune j'étais nul
les noëls à mais là je vais twitté quand
même que vous êtes la plus belle du
monde fait plaisir
ouais rare est alors pamela pamela
pamela participer à danse avec les stars
se passer et je pense qu'on est obligé
de se faire un petit assiste à un petit